thanks for having me Myanmar's
government has been ordered to take
emergency measures to prevent soldiers
committing acts of genocide against
trujillo muslims still living there the
International Court of Justice has also
ruled of Myanmar protect all evidence
for a potential genocide trial around
three quarters of a million Rohingya
fled to neighboring Bangladesh during a
military offensive against them three
years ago
Myanmar's leader denies charges of
genocide Myanmar must in accordance with
its obligations under the Convention and
in relation to the members of the
Rohingya group in its territory take all
measures within its power to prevent the
commission of all acts within the scope
of article 2 of the Genocide Convention
me Parker is covering this from The
Hague he says the ruling will be
difficult to enforce but is still a
significant development from the court
what the court has been asked to do is
rule on two things to say whether or not
it has jurisdiction and it has come back
saying it does indeed have jurisdiction
meaning a genocide trial will take place
and secondly it was asked by the Gambia
to to impose something called
provisional measures which amounts to an
emergency injunction to put the brakes
on any form of genocide all violence
what we've heard from the court a short
while ago is that there are terms on
what it wants me our mark to do wants to
make sure that it's military and all
irregular forces that work alongside it
stop all acts of violence including rape
the burning of villages mass murder the
prevention of access to medicine it says
also asked me Omar to pervert preserve
all evidence when it comes to the
ongoing trial the future trial of
genocide and are also further terms when
it comes to the timing as well it wants
Myanmar to report back four months from
today and then every six months going
forward to show exactly what it's doing
to the international community to prove
that it is actually living up to what
the ICJ the UN's highest court is now
impose
upon it Antonia movi is executive
director of legal action worldwide a
non-profit group focused on human rights
law she joins us now live from Beirut
what's your reaction to this ruling
today is momentous day I mean who would
have thought that the International
Court of Justice has made a decision a
unanimous decision a panel of seventeen
judges one appointed by selected by
Myanmar and one by Gambia of provisional
measures to prevent acts of genocide and
that Myanmar military must not commit
further acts of genocide and as we heard
earlier from your reporter not to
destroy evidence and to report back to
the court I mean it was incredible and
we represent rahega refugees who are
residing in Bangladesh and we saw their
faces and their reactions that the world
has taken note and the highest court in
the land has has made this decision it's
really very very landmark today and
going forward what does that mean you
know the rahaga have been seeking
justice we've been helping them to try
to obtain that and this is an incredibly
important step even though it may take
years for the full trial to to go ahead
yeah but the as I understand it that the
court's decision is unenforceable I mean
me and not does not have to comply it
could just ignore the ruling well it is
a legally binding decision and I think
let's go back to the hearings in in
December and some suci herself went to
represent her country and I think that's
very significant that shows us that she
and Myanmar have actually engaged in
these proceedings so it is legally
binding of course it's a million dollar
question will Myanmar comply they do
have very strict reporting provisions
that have been requested by the court
what happens if they don't it would have
to go to the UN Security Council I think
here is going to be really important
that we continue international pressure
on Myanmar to abide by its legal
obligations and also those that are in
Bangladesh watch to see what happens to
the ringer and when they come if they
have to
still Myanmar into Bangladesh there we
take their stories and hear what they
have to say so I think now we're going
to see what will be the reaction and of
course to till now we haven't seen a
response from an sung Suchi to the
court's decision yeah I was going to ask
you what this means for Aung San su Qi
given that she denied that a genocide
had occurred in Myanmar you know I would
love to be a fly on the wall right now
and seeing what designs sung su Qi think
to this you know Human Rights icon and
there she was at The Hague now defending
the actions of the Myanmar military and
I was there in The Hague with some of
the ringer refugees who had fled during
the 2017 clearance operations
some of them who'd lost a 20-year old
widow it had nine members of her family
killed and subjected to very serious
sexual violence and who'd wanted to just
reach out in the court against an sung
su Chi I think that she had said before
to the world she didn't know what was
happening
she cannot deny that and the highest
court in the land has also said to take
action now to prevent further acts to
protect 600,000 reinga who still remain
in recurrence stay tuned Myanmar and I
think that's incredibly important we
shouldn't forget that but there's still
many reinga still residing in Myanmar
and that's absolutely crucial that
decision for them today
okay many thanks indeed good to talk to
you Antonia movi their executive
director of legal action worldwide